alors attention c'est un toc toc toc
spécial grandes voix c'est parti toc toc
toc
peut parler plus fort
qu'elle n'entend pas gens à la foudre
qui est là mais s'il est ce lui qui
laisse les rênes du pain
[Applaudissements]
là
c'est cloclo après le vaccin
j'adore
ces
bateaux
attention
vous dit le deuxième j'ai vu ça te tais
âmes sensibles s'abstenir est il à une
petit mais je vous le dis c'est
incroyable vas-y toc toc
non je sens à l'oreille c'est quelqu'un
qui a besoin d'argent
c'est possible alors au tac toc toc
jameela jamil
aquila
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais me tenir je suis l'un
fait beaucoup de mal à tout le monde
je sais mais non mais 5 mais pourquoi
mais qui se lie aux pieds frère mais
j'ai une fracture du péroné hervé alors
même été piela frères bas ils sont ici
on y est c'est le bleu de la facture
mais là c'est pareil me c'est un oignon
saison les frères c'est pas grave mais
c'est quoi ces y ait pu enfin ces
métiers qu'est ce que c'est pâques ligne
est je peux pas les changer à mes frères
mais surtout conflit là tu vas pas
qu'ils ont refait jamais été peut-être à
coucher ou quoi cette ocm
non mais attends est et ça va très très
bien mais les femmes femmes femmes et
j'ai fracture du péroné mamata soir du
sud c'est toi qui peux faire ça
t'as pas me voir comme ça alors j'espère
pas
mais tu sais le talent c'est un bon test
c'est un bon test
c'est un bon test ça fait longtemps que
je n'ai plus d'ego série brabham et à
poils longs tout bien sûr
pas tellement
la domination
mais vous on dirait une vraie personne
dix années près de personnes les genres
des années 18
500 écoles et on dirait une veine
mission tu vois et on a ressorti
sa mort et les nostalgies c'est vrai
mais tu es très belle comme ça chez
michel l'orage que daniel va bien elle
et elle n'a pas connu deux hommes depuis
26 ans
mais là c'est normalement là ça devrait
s'arranger comme ça non
j'ai aimé la action une chaise qui s'est
tourné vers daniel
espèce de vide sidéral sincères et 26
ans j'ai compris ouais ouais non mais
c'est vrai que là il peut se passer des
chats voilà merci merci michel debré
c'est sympa mais non mais c'est vrai que
là tu as trouvé ton style non mais je
pense que sur les zones mortes
sur les arbres et c'est des jeux cartes
c'est parti
c'est kamel kamel qui jamel c'est un nom
qu'on
[Applaudissements]
un oiseau qui sait elle
alors je sens l'enfer s'ouvrir à sous
mes pieds
et excusez moi pendant un peu dépressive
que
ça va ouais j'aurais remercier l'équipe
des effets spéciaux qui ont fait un
travail incroyable
c'est bien sûr ce costume a été
incroyable commerci c'est sûr je peux
servir de balai à chiotte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la gare donc si votre tina moi garou
alors là c'est le livre et le loup vous
l'avez vu qu'on
abat voir le loup avec garou là c'est le
rêve absolu
mais en tout cas cette petite voiture ou
va très bien non mais vraiment je crois
j'ai trouvé mon style ouais il ya un
délire j'aime bien j'aime bien aussi
j'aime bien jouer comme ça on a fait
ouais c'est vrai ça va ça va c'est le
cadeau dont on peut se lasser très vite
voilà
ça c'est sûr que c'est vrai mais voilà
c'est incroyable là franchement c'est
incroyable c'est dégueulasse oui
s'il n'y a pas un truc
tellement c'est que s'il n'y a rien du
tout donc si vous êtes exprimés on sait
pas une ouverture à huy hà n'ont même
pas merci allez c'est parti
mais j'ai reconnu chez valérie bénaïm
aller 0-2 fait le
dj
dj la lune
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave mais c'est pas la peine
de faire des batailles
comme à des trucs comme à droite grâce
parce que sur ce on installe avec une
grande boîte à versailles comme ça et
donc tourner à copier mais en fait t'as
pas du tout mes perruques non mais c'est
vrai que sur 100 g amel bent mais sur
glane ouais ouais pas joli donc toi tu
es amel bent des amalgames dans une
version
alpha voilà maintenant
[Rires]
bon alors là je vous le dis tout de
suite tristesse à venir
moment de tristesse moment de solitude
comme à chaque fois
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
et
alors
il
oui cette personne a une famille
[Applaudissements]
moi je veux revoir son entrée il est
rentré comme non mais sans déconner on
peut palomba déjà l'asie regardez
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
comment ça
il est un peu plastic bertrand mais
franchement
je vous presse numéro un pour leur
marché
oui j'y crois
il ya quelqu'un qui va venir vous
chercher
[Rires]
on dirait vraiment les gâtés dans
l'émission genre ça commence aujourd'hui
comme si aulas est né un peu comme à
signer en dépression
mais c'est un truc de ouf tatoué folle
parce que toi tu es vraiment yahya yahya
des bois d'arette ouais ça va om et
naïve à la loi heures c'est l'oeil quand
même une belle personne comme vous
c'est parti toc toc
c'est vraiment vraiment kiffe
raymond où vivent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
c
petite question
pourquoi daniel a eu droit de passage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur
la même face à
toi tu as une tout et c'est ma maman tu
as ta télé dans faites entrer l'accusé
sans déconner tuer des gens par avec toi
alors je te jure fusil samba là ça
serait super bien
le titre le boucher de guingamp
non mais vraiment bravo en tout cas je
continue quand je vois ça je me dis
bravo a créé des vingt sept à trois
petits cachets
alors c'est une nouvelle qui remplace
kelly au pied levé
non mais ta gueule
[Rires]
qu'est ce que tu veux déjà
non mais je n'étais pas demander comment
tu t'appelles
mal
en vrai que tu appelles comme en alsace
bah moi je m'appelle wesh des
j'ai préparé cette vente depuis ce
match
a dit tu hors de ma vue s'il te plaît ok
mais comment six mois laure va dire
alors on fait le bail ok on refait toute
attaque
à mal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cela rentrer sans rien dire
je vous dis on je vous le dis on avait
un problème de réalisation le rallye
c'est donc tapas us ou
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va ça va tu vas rester comme
ça toutes les missions non
tu peux laisser de la place de koné sera
possible comment ça va dit sa savane
kénitra alors à nice a rappelé dany ça
ouais whitera maman a fait mario pour
les regarde exactement ce qu'on en voit
d'ailleurs que maman ok mais
comment s'appelle qui s'appelle cécile
brèche et qu'elle avait un petit croche
sur web en plus à winneway ouais j'ai
senti que j'avais voulu dire mais j'ai
vu le beau
jeu quand elle est venue j'ai vu les
mecs quand il ya un crunch c'est tout tu
t'y cendres j'ai vu ça ça darron el
maoui ouais j'ai vu j'ai vu que aliou
sall je l'adoré très sympathique merci
d'être là ma chérie mais de quoi merci
de m'avoir invité alors t'es pas inviter
les invités c'est michel rocard s'était
très vite là mais de quoi faire te le
dire c'est une en mai c'est vrai c'est
bon voilà que tu as quel âge 19 ans 19
ans 20 ans le vide foot qu'est ce que
j'en ai à [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu fais quoi dans la vie rien
ça pour montrer je me disais ouais
bonne idée ou une nana qui fait rien
noté contente d'être avec nous oui on a
dit ça c'est tête à l'école jusqu'à quel
âge
six à dix neuf ans
c'était à 17 ans oui ça fait une phobie
scolaire en fait à une phobie scolaire
aussi ils ont la phobie du travail non
mais je crois que vous avez tous un
point commun vous ne voulez rien [ __ ]
ta une phobie scolaire nous écrase à ok
ça va toi sinon ouais ça vanne qu'elle
est contente winch contente est contente
elle est allée est râpé pour rappeler
qu'ils sont fiancés ah oui et si on se
rencontrait il avait rencontré une bonne
mais en fait il est parti avec anissa
c'est fou ce crossover à nice matin mais
c'est fou ça votre nom savate et pat
c'est pas trop dur de voir des personnes
aussi
tous mais
voilà quelqu'un qui pourra dire toutes
les conneries
mais eux on enchaîne à ali n'a encore 3
et ses parties
ces rites habitat
[Applaudissements]
n
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est minimaliste
mais
je te jure qu'il ya quelque chose c'est
un soutien m qui revisite elle tient un
truc qu'est-ce que tu serais pas pousser
la barbe
déconner
tu as vu qu'ils avaient une nouvelle à
nice a carrément je les ai vus elle est
charmante elle est ravissante et
pétillante sais pas
je suis soulagé parce que je voulais
mabille exactement que l'homme anissa
est heureux d'échanger ou
tata opté pour une tenue plus plus du
plus sportswear sport à nice elle a fait
une stomie scolaire un fait tout ça
ouais hein ça va vraiment regarde
comment ta maman elle te regarde on gc
oui sûrement ça va tu sais toujours qui
s'est
fait tout à fait une phobie matin
une phobie par le
rappel d'accord mais battre et aller
en tout cas si je sois faire derrière
tout cas je sens la virilité d'art
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est parti vanille bon quand même
les coupes annoncées plus de personnages
à vélo soit pas que son client telle
annonce était qu'à toronto montant bien
oui mais là je suis plus mon personnage
est latente en dix minutes je respire
non mais
c'est pas ça je peux te dire j'ai pas
respecté samedi on a peur de tout péter
ions et phobie scolaire la rue brune sur
l'artistique et les mages te dit tout
haut d'un arrêt de beaune en spectacle
devant tout le monde d'accord mais bat
il va rentrer à la maison tu vas prendre
un cachet tu as touché nos
shows tu vas savoir ce que c'est
ça me faire chier
allez vas-y alors j'y vais c'est topless
et on la voit pas que c'est sûr tu
attends depuis gmail je fais quand je
sens artistique c'est quand tu le sens
et pas qu'en te demande répondent à
michèle laroque tu sers à dresser des
partisans des blessés ça je te dit tu
vas rentrer dans le droit chemin bon
allez vas-y jbl on est pauvre en
bourrant motif est allouée à moi je peux
dire que tu crées la main dans ma fille
y aller allons-y porte c'est bon dans
l'ordre
toc toc toc qui est c'est manu manu key
man u et
[Applaudissements]
je veux pas faire mon choix
du coup j'ai
pour ma part de monsieur
viendrait bien de tuer john une deuxième
fois
michel tu veux féliciter en plus
pourquoi parce que tu inventes à nouveau
pas bien sûr le moonwalk arrange
les affaires mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça
avec une perruque sachez-le préfère
plusieurs c'est vrai que la base avec
johnny
eddy la scène johnny vegas
las et catherine deneuve
c'est encore d'année le monde
l'internet
merci
non nous nous calons g8 série ça va
alors se dit oui pour ça va faire grand
bruit dans le milieu de la danse c'est
gentil je l'avais testé la première fois
un autre de nos wii ou alors tu
t'attends tu vas me dire qu'ils étaient
dans une boîte de nuit allongé comme à
ce naturopathe faire du moonwalk et
bonne tenue de chez nous on est souvent
plus horizontaux que oui tout à fait
quoi et tu te balader comme ça non mais
c'était rigolo comme ça c'est la boîte
de la musique est parti et puis quoi il
a territoire moonwalk allongé mais
l'artiste a parlé quoi comment
t'expliquer et saint-michel le secteur
qui s'était dit qu'on ne refait pas je
ne savais pas que j'ai lancé resnais je
suis un artiste c'est déjà clair sur un
testicule
non
mais pas partout je te paie déjà
quelqu'un qui vit des moments difficiles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]